[Music]
hey you guys time for another book
review now this you're gonna think this
is kind of hilarious but i actually uh
chose this book uh it was another one
that was free on kindle unlimited and i
was like wow the name of that author
gemma amore that sounds really familiar
and i kind of heard a lot about this
book like i heard i saw the cover around
a lot and on a bunch of other booktubers
channels and after i read the book and
then i was like writing uh notes about
it and everything like that and then i
realized oh yeah i've already read one
of her books not this one obviously that
would be really stupid but i had
actually read one of her books before
six rooms and i in and i uh reviewed
that like not too long ago if you
remember but i completely i was so
that's why her name was familiar because
i'd already read see i read so i read so
many books that i can't remember like
from one day to the next uh so yeah but
so i had read six rooms so this is
actually her 2019 novella dear laura
and
so this is actually the second thing of
hers that i'd read now she's a british
writer i think she lives in bristol
and i think she kind of first came onto
the scene back in 2018 so fairly
recently
she put out a collection of short
stories called cruel works of nature
she's also a writer for the no sleep
podcast and she also does there's a
podcast called calling darkness and
she's like a co-creator of that and does
the writing and does like voice acting
on it as well
and she's uh published a few other books
the aforementioned six rooms which came
out in 2021 which i've read she also had
a novel called white pines and then she
did a short story collection called till
the score is paid i think is called and
it was illustrated but it doesn't really
appear to be available anymore like it
looks like it's still on amazon but they
said it's like out of print i'm not
really sure so maybe it was like a
limited edition not really sure about
that but like i said the one we're
talking about is called uh dear laura
this is a novella it's only about 120
pages and it came out in 2019.
so the story is pretty uh brief and very
straightforward
uh despite that though it covers like a
really long time period it covers like
essentially one person's almost their
whole entire life or at least in from
when they're 13 until they're you know
kind of older
so you know so it covers a lot of ground
and again despite it being very short
it does have like a really lot of depth
to it and a lot of layers to it um as in
regards to this sort of like lifelong
trauma uh that you know strikes the
protagonist
so laura is the main character
obviously from the title
now when we start the book she's
actually a 13 year old school girl uh
you know in the uk presumably
now her best friend is this boy named
bobby
who's two years older than her so he's
15
and she's known him pretty much all her
life i guess like her their families are
you know neighbors and so they kind of
like grew up together
uh you know and her you know families
like know each other as well
uh so they've been pretty much
inseparable since they were both very
very young however uh now that they've
gotten into their teenage years and
those hormones have started raging or
whatever uh they've started to develop
some sort of new and kind of awkward
feelings toward one another and they
decide that they're going to quote
unquote go steady which at this point
like i said she's 13 and he's 15. um you
know so it seems like a little chased
where they're just kind of
holding hands and stuff like that but
it's a little bit like i said awkward
for them because they've known each
other all their lives but now they're
kind of trying to navigate
this new sort of like relationship type
of thing and they don't really know
how to behave
now a lot of this
uh kind of vibe
is not really spelled out because this
part of the book is actually really
really short it's only like a few pages
so a lot of it is conveyed through
suggestion and stuff like that so it's
not really like gone super into but that
was like
but that's kind of the thing about gemma
o'moore's writing is that she conveys a
lot with like not a lot of words which i
think is like really good
now it so happens that the first day
that
laura and bobby are like an official
couple
is also laura's birthday
so it's a weekday her and bobby are
standing at the bus stop as they do
pretty much every weekday morning
and they're just standing there hand in
hand not really talking to each other
like i said it's awkward because now oh
now we're boyfriend girlfriend they
don't really know how to act you know
what i mean so there's that kind of
thing
so while they're standing there waiting
uh this blue van pulls up not too far
away like to the curb
laura can't see who it is that's driving
it uh although she does get them she
just kind of sees him in shadow she gets
the impression that it's like a very
large like a very bulky man
now oddly uh bobby just walks over to
the van and kind of leans in the
driver's side window and starts talking
to the dude like without saying anything
to her like you know like hey wait a
minute or hey i know that guy or
anything like that he just goes over
there and starts talking to the guy
now from laura's perception she said it
doesn't exactly look like he knows that
dude but it doesn't really look like
he's super afraid of him either and
we're not really entirely sure why like
i said he's like a 15 year old kid and
he's kind of he's very tall he says and
uh you know so he kind of has to
lean down a little bit like to talk to
the guy like inside the car
and they seem like they're talking and
you know bobby kind of laughs and [ __ ]
like that
and then very weirdly bobby just like
walks around the van and gets into the
passenger side
so obviously laura is just kind of like
looking at him like what the [ __ ] bro
like what are you doing like where are
you going
and she finds it very weird that bobby
doesn't like look back at her like he
almost kind of like looks down in his
lap and like he won't meet her eyes so
she's just like standing there going
like what where are you going
and
he doesn't ever answer
so then the van drives away and not
surprisingly because this is a horror
novel bobby is never seen again like he
goes missing
obviously because this is her best
friend she's known him all her life uh
laura falls into a profound depression
because of this
not only because that's her best friend
and now her new boyfriend but also
because she
blames herself she's like why didn't i
do something to prevent it like why
didn't i run over there and be like hey
what are you doing she she feels like
she could have stopped it from happening
so she feels really guilty
and the [ __ ] up thing is that bobby's
parents
also kind of low-key blame her a little
bit
um and she's sort of like two i mean
she's only 13 so she's too young to
realize that it absolutely was not her
fault and that these adults are kind of
being shitty like blaming her like she
could have done something like i said
she was just a 13 year old girl
so as if all this situation isn't bad
enough for a child that age
on laura's next birthday so a year after
bobby's disappearance
this weird dirty yellow envelope comes
through her letterbox
and obviously it hasn't been mailed
because there's not any postage on it
and uh and it has her name on it just
says laura on it
so she opens this letter now the person
that's written the letter is known only
as x that's what they sign the letters
as
x claims to know where bobby is
and says i will give you clues to how
you can find him
if you do
some
increasingly creepy i guess you'd call
them favors but he wants things from her
i don't want to spoil too much about
this and it's like so it's like really
hard and it's pretty short um so you
know like i said it's kind of like hard
to talk about without spoiling too much
about it but let's call it favors but he
wants things from her in exchange for
clues to where bobby is
so if she does what he asks in the
particular letter like he'll send her in
the next letter he'll send her like a
series of coordinates and she'll go out
there and then it's sort of like a
i don't know like a like a treasure hunt
i guess which is sort of [ __ ] up but
it's looking for her best friend
so the rest of the story kind of goes on
in the same way so every birthday she
gets another letter like another yellow
envelope and
laura at this point is just every year
is becoming more and more sort of like
traumatized and beaten down
by
the increasingly skin crawling requests
that this dude is making and she's also
getting really frustrated because even
though he keeps like dangling in front
of her that you know
trying to find out like clues to where
bobby is he basically keeps sending her
all these coordinates and she goes there
and then there's like nothing there and
so she's getting really mad about it but
she also is still pretty young and she
doesn't really know i mean the thing
about it is that x kind of like
threatens her and it becomes clear later
on that he's actually watching her so
he's basically like you know don't go to
the police or you're gonna regret it and
she doesn't want to at first because she
kind of feels like oh well
you know after it happens a few times
she's like oh well it's too late now
because they'll ask why didn't you come
sooner and blah blah like if this guy
apparently like knows who he is or was
the one that took bobby and so she's
afraid that she's gonna get in trouble
and it almost as the story goes on they
always sort of develop like i said this
this spans like a really long time
period like it starts when she's 13
and
ends when she's probably like in her
late 30s and then like jumps ahead to
when she's like an older woman like i
said i can't spoil too much about it
because like [ __ ] happens after that
but
it's almost like this weird
i want to call it sort of like grooming
but it's also sort of like this
symbiotic sort of like dependency
that develops between x and laura and as
i said um he's not bullshitting like he
is actually watching her because one
time when she gets a little bit older
and you know kind of you know grows a
pair of ovaries and says i'm going to
take all this [ __ ] to the police because
he sends her some like absolute evidence
that he was the one that took bobby
and so she takes all the letters and
everything and she's going to go to the
cops and basically he like attacks her
so he's like following her around
um so she knows that she can't really
that you know and he seems to find her
like wherever she goes so she can't
really like go to the cops uh or
something bad will happen
so as i said the tail is like pretty it
just pretty much goes on like that and
it's pretty direct uh it's about 120
pages now what it does the story sort of
alternates between
the present day when she's i think in
her maybe late 30s or early 40s and
she's going out to
the one of these clues or one of these
locations that the guy has sent her you
know the like he does every year
and then uh so so it'll be a chapter
like that and then the next chapter will
be like a flashback like going back to
when she was younger and like one
particular thing that happened like when
she was 13 or when she was 16 or
whatever so it kind of like alternates
like that like pretty much through the
whole story and then the last few pages
kind of like jump forward in time and
sort of wrap everything up although it
does leave a few questions unanswered
which
i don't know it kind of bothered me a
little bit but then i was like well i
guess it doesn't really bother me
because in the universe of the book
her character we see everything from her
perspective and you know if it was just
her she wouldn't know you know a lot of
the things that i was just kind of like
well what about this and how did bobby
know that guy or whatever you know what
i mean so she wouldn't have known that
so
the reader doesn't know either so it
does leave a few questions unanswered
but it does wrap up a lot of things at
the end
so overall i found this like a really
compelling very powerful
read
um and the way that the main character
laura just kind of gets into this
horrible like spiraling
despair
because
she kind of feels like she wants i mean
she she pretty much knows that bobby is
dead
but
she has this compulsion
to
find his body or like find out what
happened to him like she can't let it go
because she blames herself still because
it happened when she was so young
and so
just she gets
more and more like wrapped up in this
like [ __ ] up relationship with this
guy that keeps like sending her these
letters and asking her these like really
creepy things like to give him these
creepy things
and so
like kind of her downfall and like how
her pretty much entire childhood and
early
you know her young adulthood
has been pretty much [ __ ] up by this
dude and it's like and he's just casting
a paw over her entire life and so this
like really [ __ ] up like again like
this really sick relationship that
develops between the two of them so i
thought that was like really really good
and like really traumatic and creepy a
lot of the trauma and emotion in this is
like really really deeply felt and as i
said gemma moore is really good at
conveying a lot with not that much text
you know what i mean she gets across
kind of a whole ocean of emotions with
just sort of like a sentence you know
what i mean so i really really liked
that so even though this is really short
there's a really lot of stuff going on
uh beneath the surface i will note there
were a couple of because here it's i'm
gonna put on my my grammar nazi hat here
um there were a couple of like
grammatical things that it didn't like
take me out of the story because they
were fairly minor but i noticed them
because that's how i do because i'm like
i have grammar ocd
uh one of them because i wrote them down
i was like oh i don't and i don't
usually do that but this one is just
kind of like i don't know it bothered me
um there was one point where
she meant to say like a hanger like a
clothes hanger but she spelled it like
ar like an airplane hanger so there was
that um and i don't know if that was her
if that was an editor i don't really
know what it was uh so there was that
and then there was one place where it
was supposed to say septic like a like a
wound had gone septic but it said
skeptic instead like with the c which is
the british spelling there was also one
place and this kind of bugged me because
laura when she gets older she actually
works at a grocery store like stocking
shelves at night because she doesn't
really like to be around a lot of people
uh because of this kind of ongoing
secret that she has so she doesn't
really like to hang out with people
because she's afraid that they'll find
out what's going on so that's kind of
established but then at the beginning of
one chapter it says she
she switched to day shift i can't
remember exactly why because she wanted
to be around more people because she was
like after she got attacked and she was
afraid she's like she got so she
switched to day shift so more people
would be around but then like literally
four or five paragraphs later it implied
that she was still working the night
shift so again that's you know i i just
think that maybe it could have taken
another pass or an editor but those were
really the only thing ones that i
noticed but like i said and that's me
being like super super nitpicky because
you know how i do about the grammar and
the spelling and everything like that um
you know so it was just like a couple
things that i noticed but
uh overall this was a pretty great and i
read it like really quickly like i said
it's pretty short and
it'll just have you
kind of on the edge of your seat kind of
because you're just like waiting for
each new letter and it's like now what's
gonna happen now just stuff keeps
escalating so it's like really really
good like that so if you're looking for
something just like a really quick read
it's kind of psychologically [ __ ] up
because this kind of like weird
symbiotic relationship sort of develops
between
her and
this person that presumably took her
best friend a boyfriend um and it also
has kind of like a strange like
poignancy to it because of the
complete like loss of her youth i guess
loss of her youth and innocence and the
fact that she can't escape uh the trap
of like this relationship with this
person just because because she can't
let it go that she has to find out what
happened to bobby it's just not you know
she's just not gonna let it go ever
so
yeah i would definitely definitely
recommend this um it's if you have
kindle unlimited uh you can read it on
there for free um i think i liked this
one a little bit better than six rooms i
remember liking that one quite a bit um
although
they're i can't remember like i know i
did a review of that one but i think i
like this one a little better it was
just more concise i guess and it was
just like i liked that it was just like
this constantly like developing mystery
and it was like really straightforward
and so you were just kind of like well
[ __ ] and then what happened and then
what happened so it was like really good
it was a really really quick read so
yeah i would definitely definitely uh
recommend this one so that will do it
for this installment of tones of terror
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye